welcome back to another episode of the
iced coffee hour we're coming to you now
on a Saturday because uh we were having
a business talk and we figured instead
of just having it behind closed doors we
may as well just film and monetize it
and post an extra episode because it's
been a long time since the three of us
were together filming these we stopped
doing them because uh we didn't want to
over saturate it with too much content
yeah and I also heard there were some
important changes that you guys said you
wanted to talk to me about so it's a
huge changes yeah so arguably the
biggest change here that's ever gonna
happen I'm excited for that but let's
hold off on that a little bit we gotta
we gotta slowly creep into that so first
of all let's talk about the New York
trip oh yes yes what did we do in New
York first of all give us a give us a
recap that was an insane trip so I've
not traveled in such a long time for
like podcasts right
um you know we'll go to La every now and
then if we have a guest down there but
uh not like a dedicated trip but we did
like six oh we did so many episodes
seven it was incredible we got so far
ahead in just like four days of filming
now with the time we're posting this we
have I think 12 episodes in the pipeline
that are already filmed that is
absolutely 12 of them so it's like four
a month it's like months worth of
content right now I feel sorry for the
editor yeah it's gonna be it's gonna be
rough but uh it's better for you guys
because these 12 episodes are some of
the best episodes we've ever shot I'm
not just saying that I'm not just saying
yeah we're actually traveling to guests
right now and so we're able to book
people that I would never imagine that
we'd ever be able to book especially New
York my favorite one was Dr Mike I was a
huge Doctor Mike then if you guys
haven't seen the episode go just look up
ice coffee or Dr Mike I think we spent
an hour and a half talking to him and it
was incredible that's funny because Alex
hardly ever fangirls but when we were
showing up to Dr Mike's apartment he was
like giddy he was like we were in the
elevator and I swear he was shaking
because he was so excited to meet Dr
Mike I think he like piddled himself as
soon as he walked through I was did you
think I was like excited like Bailey
when I walked oh yeah
yeah if you guys don't know Graham's dog
gets very excited that's when she's
excited yeah yeah and sometimes piddles
when you touch her
um but anyway it was interesting to to
get the perspective of a doctor who beat
somebody up yeah because he went against
his oath as a doctor hormone to others
yeah so and then uh for the main Channel
we met Barbara Corcoran and Barbara
Corcoran was fantastic but we also met
Ryan sirhant and the 250 million dollar
list
Jack decided to sleep we've already
hashed this out on the podcast okay it
was not me sleeping on it it was 7 A.M
okay that was 4 a.m we met at nine it
was 9 A.M 6 a.m West Coast time so it
was like four days to adjust Jack had
longer Jack was already there when we
got there so Jack was adjusted I was
adjusted and it was 9 A.M on the time of
the East Coast yeah I'm gonna bring
people up to speed because it does kind
of lead into what we were talking about
earlier
um a 250 million dollar listing it's the
most expensive listing right now in the
United States it's the tallest
residential building in the world and we
got a tour of it for the main Channel I
invited Jack if Jack wanted to come and
see this place it's like 1300 feet up in
the air just to get an idea the only
time that people get to view this place
you can't just go and schedule a tour
you have to be vetted and in order to
like afford this place you have to be a
multi-billionaire yes like and the
security in this building is so tight
nobody's getting in right so this is
like a once in a lifetime opportunity I
just want to make that clear yeah
probably less than maybe
150 people in the world right uh I've
been invited to this Penthouse once it's
been what's the goal of this right here
is it to make it seem like I've changed
or something my guys because here let me
know
let me just finish the story yeah okay I
invite Jack Jax well you know do I need
to be there and I'm like you don't need
to be there but it's good for you to be
there well it's kind of early and I
might be out late I might just leave I
saw that other really expensive property
in California like the same and I was
like and I backed off at that point what
do you want to say I mean okay the only
thing that I wanted and it noted the
difference between you with Christine
when you looked at her like two million
dollar Diamond uh wedding ring wedding
ring or whatever probably like you were
Amazed by that and then now I show you
250 million dollar Penthouse you're like
they're all the same okay so there are a
lot of different things to note here so
number one above all else I don't get
that much pleasure out of looking at
like the craziest apartment the craziest
past the craziest car is like it's nice
to me but I can't even fathom I feel
like I cannot appreciate in the same way
that other people that have taste can
appreciate those things I don't know
what it is maybe it's because I'm just a
24 year old guy you know maybe it's
because like I maybe it is because I saw
Christine's you know 1.6 million dollar
ring when I was like 19 or 20 or
whatever and that was like
earth-shattering to me I don't know what
it is but it doesn't excite me the same
way that it used to and I'm sorry if
that sounds pompous I'm sorry if that
sounds like ridiculous it's just a
personal preference and I can't explain
it any other way that's just who I am I
don't get excited over stuff like that I
kind of realized especially with that
experience that the one thing that
really matters to me is just like my
time and I want to spend it doing the
things I truly care about and if that
means skipping out on going to go see
the most expensive listing in the United
States to go hang out with my friends
and just spend quality time with them go
to a coffee shop relax and chat maybe
read then that's how I'm gonna spend it
I just feel like your 20s are a time for
like you to double down right now like
we have a huge opportunity I think that
the networking that you get from going
to those listings from Meeting those
people yeah but the thing is I was going
to meet someone that we were shooting a
podcast with exactly because that was a
different experience because we were
going to hang out with Inez who I wanted
to talk to because I I like him as a
friend oh so you don't like Ryan I do
like Ryan's friend but I knew for a fact
we were shooting a podcast with them
later that day and another thing is I
make sure yes I'm like kind of trying to
look at it through the scope of an 80 20
rule it's like I can go and I can get a
couple extra hours of sleep and be that
much more like I guess energetic on the
podcast because we had like three
podcasts to shoot after the listing yeah
so I wanted I wanted to make sure that
like I was good for you guys to make
sure I had enough energy I wanted it
just didn't seem like the smartest thing
for me to do at the time nor something
that I really was super excited I just
think you could suck it up for like a
week of course I can suck it up for a
week but I just didn't want to there's
no other way that I can explain it to
you Graham I just didn't want to I think
Jack just really values his time and you
know to a degree I don't think there's
anything wrong with that you know I
think that if he's paying the bills he's
living below his means you know and Jack
used to be a hustler like doing
everything like no matter what you throw
Jack you would do it he would do it
early he would give us all and now I
feel like he's like you know what we
could Outsource this we could Outsource
that and now In fairness a lot of that
stuff has not resulted in a dip in
quality so a lot of that like I've just
been if anything it kind of freed up
some of everybody's time yes yeah I
still feel like there's something to it
when you got your heart and soul and
something I agree I think it matters to
spend a good amount of time on a project
but I don't think that you need to spend
every waking hour on a project and I
also think that I will yield poor
returns instead of spending five quality
hours on something
um just like devoting every single last
waking breath into one thing it's just
exhausting it's unsustainable so I think
if you spend fewer quality hours into
something and you can Outsource the
things that you don't necessarily need
to be doing you can find cheaper labor
that does it better more effectively
that makes sense to me and that's been
my experience through Outsourcing the
few things that I have I think it's made
all of our Lives easier but then as well
it's been more profitable doing like I
don't know what you do all day recently
honestly I've been reading a lot
so yeah I get it guys I think the
tensions are high because we kind of
discussed what I was planning on
discussing on this podcast here with you
guys today which is the big change for
the iced coffee hour I understand why
you might be a little upset by it but
like I said I think that this is really
how we're going to take the podcast to
the next level and it sounds so silly it
sounds so ridiculous I didn't really
understand what you were saying earlier
I'll explain it I'll explain
um is that I think that it actually
makes sense for me to go and experience
real life things to become as
interesting as a person as I possibly
can to share those stories with you guys
through someone I'm Outsourcing the
talent position of sitting in front of
the microphone too so you're leaving the
iced coffee hour I'm not leaving the
iced coffee hour per se but I'm gonna be
remote speaking to a sit-in with a
headset I kind of started getting these
thoughts when we had Encore on the
podcast and he says that two things make
you a more interesting person which is
reading and traveling experiences so
that's really how I want to be spending
my time because I think it's important
if my job is to speak for a living that
I am an interesting person I think I
should go and get experiences and I
think I should go read more so I think
that really is where I'm going to get
the most amount of value and increase
the quality of this podcast the most and
someone can sit in for me so you're
going to be zooming in to when we do a
podcast no it's not necessarily going to
be zooming in but I okay it's gonna be
hard to explain but what I think would
be really helpful is if we actually did
like a simulation of what it's going to
look like right here I look I'm let's
just let him try it
all right hey guys this is Andrew I'm uh
filling in for Jack today uh he hired me
to be in a a fill-in for him in the
podcast uh and uh so he's gonna feed me
what he wants to say through the
headphones and then he's gonna hear the
rest of the the room through the mic
um so I'm super excited uh yeah oh what
do you think about it I mean the thing
is we could try it I mean my thought is
that Jack's thrown out some ideas in the
past that I thought were really bad but
they've turned out okay let's pretend
I'm a guest so let's say I'm uh has a
prominent YouTuber uh no I mean we were
going to talk anyway about um do you
want to talk about like weight loss yeah
sure I'm done I'm down for that yeah man
honestly um you know I've been
struggling a little bit with the weight
loss uh you know it's been a very very
remote can you say that again yeah I've
been struggling with the weight loss you
know and um it's it's not been easy yeah
so it's just been really tough I mean it
you know it's I've been battling a lot
of hurdles
why have you been battling a lot of
turtles Alex hurdles Jack hurdles
okay yeah so it hasn't been it hasn't
been that good but you know I I have I'm
back on track a little bit you know and
uh and I another thing that I've been
really looking forward to is I'm
considering attending college and the
reason yeah normally I would say you
know whatever waste of money I know I
know I know but my family being
immigrants and stuff um nobody really
got the opportunity to go to college and
I feel like it's kind of a waste of I
don't go so yeah you know because of
that and my family never got the chance
to go I've just I've really considered
going and I'm not sure my mind's not
completely made up yet gotcha but yeah
back to the weight loss thing I mean uh
at least my clothes still fit me and my
wife still loves me right but uh yeah
it's been really hard and it takes a
toll on your mentor
he said that was funny what part
the first part the closed probably oh I
don't think this is working out I think
the delay the delay there's a delay with
Jack Jack can you hear me
Bailey yeah he can hear you I don't like
this uh
can you tell Jack to come back here I
don't think this is working out Jack
they said they want you back here and
it's not working out
guys seriously yeah dude it wasn't it
wasn't working out horrible it was fine
why do you he was laughing at the wrong
time no it wasn't it's not about that we
can fix the latency he laughed about my
weight
yeah but you were making a joke that it
was it was just a latency thing trust me
this is nothing that new technology
can't solve I think you guys just like
to shut down my new ideas that's it
because you're jealous that you don't
come up with them yourselves
I just think it's laziness it's not
laziness no it's what having Ingenuity
yeah no I think it's April
fools
guys come on now that was that was I
gotta say guys we tried to film that
like 10 times it was the funniest we
thought it was going to take us 10
minutes and I think it's taken us like
half an hour yes we're gonna have some
outtakes at the end so you guys
definitely want to stay for the bloopers
because trust me they're very funny and
we got an amazing podcast coming
tomorrow with Sawhill Bloom you guys are
going to want to see it check out the
iced coffee hour.club to get it to see
it before we actually post it if you
guys are interested in that uh anything
else no I think that's it it's just
gonna be an incredible episode tomorrow
thank you guys so much I'm so sorry if
we made you guys uh nervous or something
you didn't like this episode we just
thought it'd be funny to pull a little
prank on you guys we had to yep every
year so appreciate it thank you so much
Andrew for doing what you do very nice
of you were a fantastic sit-in thank you
Alex thank you Graham thank you all you
viewers subscribe follow me on Instagram
yeah dude I was cracking up so hard I'm
sorry I hope I hope we didn't ruin all
the things
good man it's been a long time since
I've been in this seat
um good yeah just you know how's the
wife great great yeah you know good
Ness
all right let's do it again
and I'm like no no more more nasally and
he's like you guys like can you stop
are you sure you want to be like doing
this Andrew and Andrew's like yeah yeah
I mean he's paying me like 30 bucks an
hour so like it's pretty good and then
you're like wait but you realize this is
like once a week and it's for like 90
minutes and he's like he shows I'm like
doing the math and he's all this was a
two-hour drive here
I drove from California from California
so you're leaving the ice coffee hour
I'm gonna be remote speaking to a sit-in
with a headset
hold on one sec
sorry oh you brought it
oh it's okay
and the microphone is so Jack can hear
the rest of the room and uh
[Laughter]
like I don't care like dude if you have
to wipe off your glass and be like hold
on I gotta clean my God I don't care
it's funny just let Just Let It Roll
Just Let It Roll I got a microphone so
we can hear the room and a headset so I
can uh hear him I'm sorry I'm sorry that
was good come on
that was it come on all right hold on
I'm so sorry okay no look don't [__] up
and just add all the ups just add all
the arms that you need don't even worry
just if you need to say um just do it
hey guys uh this is Andrew I'm uh
filling in for Jack today in the podcast
uh Jack uh hired me to be uh fill in
come on let's get this done we got we
got like two minutes left come on come
on all right yeah so it's just been
really tough I mean it you know it's
I've been battling a lot of hurdles and
hold on a second
why have you been battling a lot of
turtles Alex hurdles Jack hurdles
yeah so it hasn't but I don't know man
it's
oh no no he didn't say that
hey Andrew no no no no
um
[Music]
yeah it's really really has been a
battle I mean
we keep we can get that you know it
really has been a battle it it's
something that that's super hard for me
to do
wait wait we can cut it but uh yeah it's
been really hard and it takes a toll on
your mentor
dang it but it really is a toll on you
know on my mental health
[Music]
is that like an Xbox